um über all das was wir jetzt gehört
haben zu sprechen ist profiler markt
hofmann
herr hofmann wenn sie das jetzt hören
was es so das erste was ihnen da durch
den kopf geht
das ist eine natürlich der besonders
grausamen taten prinzipiell immer wenn
wenn kinder sterben wenn kinder ermordet
oder muss man vorsichtig sein erstmals
ist ein tötungsdelikt ob es mord ist es
dann noch die die nächste frage aber das
sind natürlich fälle die selten
passieren fälle die schockieren und bei
aller bei aller psychologie und auch bei
allen profiling fragt man sich dann
natürlich auch trotz allem warum ein
mensch so etwas tut und oder oder wie
oder warum es dazu kommen kann ja auch
wenn natürlich motive immer eine gewisse
erklärung sind aber man muss immer den
unterschied machen zwischen motiven und
rechtfertigungen natürlich gibt es so
sich der täterinnen oder täter irgendein
motiv warum sie das tun aber ganz offen
gesagt trennungs probleme
trennungsschmerz und problemen mit dem
ex partner hatten wir möglicherweise
alle schon mal wir morgen aber nicht
oder wir töten nicht aus diesen gründen
deswegen ist das immer ein teil der
erklärung aber auch nie die ganze
erklärung ja wir haben jetzt gehört dass
die kinder wahrscheinlich sediert und
erstickt wurden was ja irgendwie so ein
bisschen meiner meinung nach dafür
spricht dass die mutter das so
schmerzlos wie möglich machen wollte ja
man muss sagen wenn man sich vergangene
fälle anschaut und sich anschaut dann
oder in welchen fällen typischerweise
eltern ihre kinder töten tatsächlich ist
dies eines der wenigen delikte wo öfter
die mütter also frauen die täter sind
als die väter als die männer
wir haben es bei fast allen
gewaltstraftaten eher andersrum ist ist
es so wenn eltern ihre kinder töten sind
häufiger mütter die täterinnen das gilt
allerdings insbesondere dann wenn wir
über sehr sehr junge kinder sprechen das
heißt wenn wir über kinder innerhalb der
ersten 24 stunden ihres lebens sprechen
dann sind ganz häufig mütter die die
täterinnen oder wenn wir kinder
innerhalb des ersten lebensjahres wenn
wir über diesen zeitraum sprechen
das alter der kinder ein zwei und drei
jahre sechs und acht jahre das heißt
hier geht es nicht darum dass ein kind
ungewollt war und direkt nach der geburt
getötet oder oder nicht angenommen nicht
versorgt wurde das ist hier nicht der
fall sondern da muss man nach an
gründen nach anderen motiven suchen
diese kategorie von tötungsdelikt nennt
man auch viele zieht wenn wenn mütter
ihre kinder töten
die über ein jahr alt sind das ist noch
eine wichtige abgrenzung und da gibt es
einige kategorien die man
auseinanderhalten kann und eine
kategorie das nennt sich altruistischer
felicitas das geht häufig mit selbstmord
oder selbstmordversuchen einher das
bedeutet mit wollen aus irgendwelchen
gründen aus dem leben scheiden das heißt
sie selber haben eine lebenskrise ein
lebens bankrott wissen nicht mehr weiter
wissen keine lösung und sehen keine
hoffnung mehr für sich das ist das motiv
für den suizid oder den suizidversuch
aber jetzt ist die frage was hat es
eigentlich mit den kindern zu tun also
selbst wenn sie sich das leben nehmen
würde oder genommen hätte warum tötet
sie dann ihre kinder
das hat zwei gründe erstens sehen diese
mütter die kinder wie eine art
erweiterung von sich selbst sie sehen
oftmals die kinder gar nicht als
getrennte persönlichkeiten sondern in
gewisser weise als ein teil von ihnen
als anteil von sich und deswegen ist es
für sie für die täterinnen die logische
konsequenz das werden sie aus dem leben
scheiden sie ihre kinder natürlich
mitnehmen und oftmals ist die
rechtfertigung dabei ich will doch meine
kinder nicht allein lassen um es in
einem satz zu formulieren
das heißt sie selbst verlassen die welt
sehen keine hoffnung mehr sehen keine
perspektive mehr
und sie wollen aber auch ihre kinder in
dieser aus ihrer sicht schrecklichen und
grausamen welt nicht alleine lassen das
heißt in gewisser weise
wohlbemerkt aus sicht der täterinnen tun
sie damit was gut ist sie bewahren die
kinder vor einer schrecklichen welt oder
einem schrecklichen leben und nehmen sie
sozusagen mit in den tod
dass dies hier zutrifft da spricht schon
einiges dafür
trotzdem gibt es noch viele fragen offen
sind ist sie überhaupt schuldfähig
inwiefern war sie schließlich haben
vielleicht auch medikamente oder drogen
oder alkohol noch eine rolle gespielt
da muss man nun abwarten bis die
vernehmungsfähig ist und man auch mit
ihr sprechen kann sie ist wahrscheinlich
die einzige person die diese frage
beantworten können wird vielleicht gibt
es auch bei der auswertung von von
whatsapp chats oder leben was die
großmutter noch zu sagen hat
gibt es erkenntnisse darüber das kann
man so nicht sagen aber diese kategorie
ist schon relativ häufig und diese
kategorie der altruistischen felicia
also wenn mütter ihre kinder aus liebe
mitnehmen weil sie sie nicht allein in
dieser schrecklichen welt lassen wollen
das ist auch die kategorie von
tötungsdelikten
die in 50 bis 60 der fälle je nachdem
welcher studie man glaubt auch mit
suizid einhergeht das heißt das ist die
kategorie womit gehen und die kinder
kinder in den fällen mitnehmen und das
ist natürlich besonders schlimmen die
frage die vor allen dingen noch offen
ist ist warum der elfjährige junge
glücklicherweise überlebt hat wobei ich
fast sagen muss eigentlich hat sie sechs
kinder getötet weil in der haut des
elfjährigen möchte glaube ich auch
niemand stecken
sie haben gerade die frage angedeutet
also haben sie praktisch gar keine
antwort darauf warum der elfjährige
jetzt überlegt es sich ja so aussieht
wenn sie ihnen die schule geschickt hat
dann abgeholt hat zur großmutter also
hat ja irgendwie das gefühl er sollte
davon absichtlich verschont bleiben
das kann man so noch nicht sagen das
wurde ja auch in der pressekonferenz
nicht klar beantwortet sie haben jetzt
zum tathergang eigentlich nichts gesagt
oder könne nichts dazu sagen denn man
muss dazu sagen
bei äußerer gewalteinwirkungen bei
scharfer oder stumpfe gewalt wie das
immer so fachsprachlich heißt also
messer oder jegliche art von stumpfen
gegenständen oder schlägen oder auch
meinetwegen würgemale dinge die von
außen passieren das sind dinge die kann
man von außen erkennen natürlich sagt
die polizei und die staatsanwaltschaft
auch da wir müssen die obduktion
abwarten und so weiter aber trotzdem
wenn jemand erschossen wird kann man es
schon von außen sehen auch wenn man die
obduktion nicht abwartet natürlich weiß
man nie ist das fordern 8 und toth
passiert war dass die todesursache aber
bei äußerer gewalteinwirkung
insbesondere dann wenn männer töten wenn
wenn männer gewaltsam töten sieht man
das von außen wenn wir über ersticken
ertrinken und vergiften sprechen sehen
sie von außen erstmal gar nichts ja
manchmal laufen person an und aber im
wesentlichen kann es nur ein
rechtsmediziner beantworten der
sauerstoffgehalt im blut wurde die
person ist die person auf anderem wege
gestorben wurde danach ins wasser gelegt
aber ist sie ertrunken
das sind fragen die nur ein
rechtsmediziner beantworten kann dann
auch in diesem fall wenn die kinder
reglos in ihren betten liegen
dann lässt sich erst mal nicht von außen
sehen ob die jetzt vergiftet wurden oder
ob die mit einem kissen erstickt wurden
oder sonstiges und in dem fall wurde ja
auch beides gesagt es gibt auf der einen
seite hinweise auf ersticken auf der
anderen seite gibt es hinweise dass sie
zitiert also
mal ruhig gestellt wurden mit
schlafmitteln oder sonstigem und das
sind ja zwei dinge die sich gar nicht
ausschließen aber die frage ist auch da
was war eigentlich die todesursache ist
die person erstickt wurde die die person
wurden die kinder vergiftet und dazu hat
die polizei hier noch keine klaren
angaben gemacht werden
eine abschließende frage noch die mutter
wollte sich umbringen hat es also sie
lebt schwer verletzt hat sich vor den
zug geworfen
jetzt ist auch so ein bisschen die frage
wenn das zutrifft was sie gesagt haben
und sie fällt in diese kategorie und
wollte ihre kinder sozusagen aus liebe
mitnehmen was macht das dann mit der
mutter wenn sie wieder vernehmungsfähig
ist und merkt meine fünf kinder sind tot
und ich aber nicht wie sie damit leben
kann dass kann nur sie selbst
beantworten
aber natürlich ist ja hat sie auch
weiterhin eine hohe suizidgefahr denn
offensichtlich wollte sie sich ja das
leben nehmen hat abgeschlossen und auch
das töten der kinder war ja ein akt des
des abschließen sie hatte nicht vor
dafür ins gefängnis zu gehen sondern sie
wollte mit dem leben ihrer kinder und
ihrem eigenen leben abschließen
wahrscheinlich wird sie jetzt natürlich
auch hilfe oder oder betreuung bekommen
so dass erst mal auch sie weiterleben
kann und dann natürlich auch sich für
ihre taten verantworten muss aber was in
ihr jetzt gerade vorgeht was überhaupt
das motiv war und wie sie damit
weiterleben kann das kann nur sie
beantworten aber vielleicht noch ein
zwei worte zum typischen profil
betrachtet man vergangene fälle
betrachtet man fälle bei denen mütter
ihre kinder töten in verbindung mit
selbstmord oder selbstmordversuchen dann
gibt es eine art typisches profil ein
durchschnitts profil
das habe ich heute morgen bereits
genannt und zwar unabhängig von diesem
fall aber jetzt nach der pressekonferenz
gewinnt ist noch mal eine andere
relevanz weil es doch in vielen fällen
oder oder fast punktgenau zutrifft
täterinnen sind typischerweise
unabhängig von diesem fall ende 20
oftmals aus ärmeren verhältnissen das
kann ich nicht genau sagen darüber weiß
ich nichts haben selbst gewalt oder
missbrauch erlebt auch das ist unbekannt
depressionen oder selbstmord tendenzen
oder andere psychische erkrankungen sind
typisch und der wichtigste punkt user
experience rejection bei mayweather also
typischerweise erleben sie kurz vor der
tat in den mond
oder wochen vor der tat erleben sie
zurückweisung durch einen männlichen
ex-partner ja oder auch weil je nachdem
aber der partner verlässt sie eine
trennungssituation trennungsschmerz
trennungs konflikte
das ist sozusagen wesentlicher teil des
motivs sie nutzen eher die leisen morton
ertrinken vergiften ersticken
manchmal kommen drogen alkohol oder
medikamenten missbrauch hinzu sie leben
sozial isoliert sind alleinerziehend und
den 50 bis 60 prozent der fälle geht der
philly zieht der mord an dem kind oder
den kindern mit suizidversuchen oder
erfolgreichen einer erfolgreichen
selbsttötung einher
das ist wohl bemerkt dass standard
profil aber wenn man das so durchgeht
klingt es in vielerlei hinsicht fast wie
eine beschreibung dieses falls und die
polizei der gerade in der
pressekonferenz bestätigt dass das sie
selbst die trennung in dem webshop chat
mit der oma als ursache genannt hat das
einzige was mich verwundert hat ich
meine ich kenne dieses standard profil
aber was mich verwundert hatte war diese
trennung ist ein jahr her
das heißt wäre dass zwei wochen nach der
trennung passiert hätte ich sofort
gesagt hier trifft das durchschnittliche
profil zu dass die trennung ein
wesentlicher teil des motivs ist das vor
einem jahr war war ich mir in dieser
hinsicht nicht ganz sicher und da ist
auch die frage was ist in der
zwischenzeit passiert wenn die trennung
der auslöser war warum ist diese tat
nicht 2009/10 passiert die polizei oder
staatsanwaltschaft ich bin mir gar nicht
ganz sicher hat ebenfalls gesagt dass es
mit der korona situation nach dem
derzeitigen ermittlungsstand nichts zu
tun hat das würde ich so nicht ganz
bestätigen oder zumindest noch mal
genauer untersuchen denn man weiß dass
diese art von taten und auch übrigens
selbstmord suizidraten korrelieren also
sie hängen zusammen mit wirtschaftlichem
stress mit mit wirtschaftlich
schwierigen situationen eines landes das
heißt wenn es würde wenn es
wirtschaftlich katastrophal läuft und
die arbeitslosigkeit hoch ist passieren
auch diese taten häufiger natürlich ist
das keine direkte folge
meistens sagen nicht die leute ich
habt keine ausweg mehr aus finanziellen
gründen aber das ist ein faktor der dazu
kommt und ich kann mir durchaus
vorstellen ich weiß nicht ob sie
erwerbstätig war oder was ihre situation
war aber ich glaube dass corona uns alle
oder die meisten getroffen hat und das
ist ein weiterer faktor der dazu kommt
man muss das wie ich meine der berühmte
tropfen der das fass zum überlaufen
bringt auch wenn sie die trennung als
den grund annimmt oftmals ist es so wenn
im leben andere bereiche gut laufen wenn
man eine schwierige trennung hat aber
gleichzeitig hat man beruflich erfolge
steigt vielleicht auf oder es gibt
andere sollen im leben die einen halten
dann kann das durchaus auch solche taten
verhindern
wenn ein land in einer krise ist steigen
auch steigt auch die wahrscheinlichkeit
für solche taten natürlich ist das
wahrscheinlich kein direkter teil des
motivs setze ich nicht wer das nicht
wegen corona getan aber dass das ein
weiterer stressfaktor ist er dazu kommt
und das leben ziemlich schwierig machen
kann
gerade wenn die kinder nicht sich meine
stellen sie sich vor sie sind mit mit
sechs kindern sechs monate zu hause
sagen sie mir nicht dass das nicht eine
stresssituation ist die noch erschwerend
dazu kommt mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren